detura is a horse of a different color
i don't consider it a true hallucinogen
i would classify it as a deliriant
i know that it's very big in magic
and i s
i understand why because it's a
confusing
and magic depends on confusion even
stage magic depends on a certain
confusion you're looking in the wrong
place and so forth and
what detura does
it's very hard to keep control of it it
erodes the core processes of the self
so that you lose track of who you are
where you are what exactly has happened
uh
i took
i took detour several times in nepal
and had very strange experiences i mean
they're not like other psychedelic
experiences i remember sitting in my
little room in bowdoin off on the third
floor and i had an open window
and i was sitting there alone waiting
for this stuff to come on and then my
mind would wander and i would think it's
not working it's just some kind of it's
crap it's not working
and then i would kind of lose attention
and these literally ghost-like forms
wraiths
would come floating in my window like in
a cartoon and they were carrying large
sheets of newsprint
and they would release this newsprint
and it would flutter down across them
and like land across my lap and i would
fall forward and be reading these
stories and as i read
i would realize
this is it this is the answer this is
the and i would like pull out of it and
then i say it's not working
it's not working
and then go back into this weird place
well that went on for about a half an
hour and but then a more in fact this is
what i referred to this morning when i
said i've had many experiences where i
was glad nobody else was there because i
felt they would become alarmed and then
create a bro haha and what happened in
these nepali experiences is i was then
slowly became aware something was going
on so i'm sitting there waiting for this
thing to hit
suddenly i lift my leg up and throw it
behind my back and then the other one
and then put my arm through and i'm
there in this totally spazzed out
knotted position
this is weird
[Music]
very carefully unfold unfold
lay down breathe deeply and then it
would happen all over again and say
boy i'm glad nobody else is here and
this went on for hours
and i just felt you know it's telling me
i'm not for it they say you know these
things choose you and and it was it was
clearly
it was clearly not for me but then i
observed other people and they didn't
seem to be handling it too well either a
couple of days later i was in the market
buying tomatoes and i met this guy
and i said i had this detura trip but
jeez i don't know and he said yeah i'm
i'm experimenting with it too in fact
i'm i'm stoned right now and i said oh
really well you seem to be handing it
all right and then the conversation
proceeded a little more and then he made
a remark that clued me to the fact that
he thought we were in his apartment
and and so then i i felt you know this
is weird this is terrible you know we're
we're losing hold of it completely we
don't know whether you know we're agnes
or angus or it's day or night
[Music]
i would
feel the undeniable urge
to tie myself in knots to throw my arm
behind my head and my leg over my
shoulder these very tight things